many entrepreneurs like yourself aspire
to one day built a global brand a global
business something where they can say I
have customers from 17 different
countries and by the way it is a big
deal it is a very big deal however it's
no longer as big of a deal today as it
used to be 20 years ago let me explain
to why 20 years ago if you had five
contacts one in Germany one in Spain one
in South America Brazil one in China
Japan you were somebody oh my gosh this
guy has contacts all over the world
today you have hundreds of people that
follow you or you follow them on
LinkedIn Facebook Twitter and you don't
even think about it anymore because
everybody has international contacts so
before thinking about taking your
business global today I'm going to share
with you ten different things to be
thinking about if you're thinking about
taking your business globe on by the way
if you haven't yet subscribe to the
channel please click on the subtitle
right here and if you got any questions
thoughts or comments throughout the
entire video comment on the bottom
number one prior to you building a
global brand you must ask the most
important question and that is why do I
want to go global okay for instance I
was mentoring the CEO who's from Romania
and I have a business where they sell
supplies and it's batteries there's only
like literally Duracell batteries
somebody had one contract somebody had
the Energizer battery contract and they
were due to competitors and they said
listen for the battery market it's
capped I have this he has this he has
these stores the markets that sell it I
have these markets so either we're gonna
have to build our own stores or we have
to leave our country Romanian go to a
different market guess what that
argument makes sense for that CEO to
take their business global now the other
end somebody said I want to be able to
say that our business is global I said
does it bring you that much credibility
if you put an office in London and you
pay 7 grand a month just to say your
businesses globally said ah in my world
yes it is then do it not really then why
are you doing it do you just want to go
back to people it doesn't make sense
hang tight first the next thing to ask
about when it comes down to why are you
already that capped out where you're at
right now that you have to leave to
another market if yes then do it if not
ask the question over and over again
until it makes us number to say it makes
a
for you to go to another country you
want to go global okay
then you have to make a list of
countries and study the cultures so
we're thinking about going to
such-and-such plates okay weird thing
about going to this place to that place
there is like for instance we wanted to
go to Mexico okay we went to Mexico we
spent town with the biggest life
insurance company in Mexico what I
wanted to find that is is insurance sold
in Mexico face to face is that a sit
down do they come to the office do you
go to the house is it a phone call what
is it is it internet see how is it being
sold because I want to find out exactly
how that cultural response to the
product how do they feel about insurance
if I wanted to go to Qatar how does
Qatar feel about insurance how does
London feel about insurance how does UK
Britain how did German how do they feel
about Anna how does Brazil feel they
feel about hundred culturally connect
how does your product connect with their
culture and not only that how did how
does their culture work certain things
getting up lady there's certain things
that you do that you have to embrace
their culture or else it's disrespectful
to them many many countries in the
Middle East you do business certain
behaviors are extremely disrespectful
where they want to business with you so
you got to study that culture they were
thinking about going into number three
is breaking through the language barrier
anytime I go to another country that I
want to do business with that is
non-english speaking let's just say
their main language you want to speak is
their language if I'm going to France if
I'm going to South America if I'm going
to Mexico we went to Mexico I took Mario
with me Mario translated everything
because Mario speaks our language
they'll break in a language barrier if
you already are out your marketing
material or your brochures your website
email translating everything customer
service communicating with the customers
your employees that respond back there's
got to be your translation we're
automatically anything can be translated
to be Center or certain employees
customer service reps that are working
for you speak that language so they can
handle those phone calls you've got to
be able to break through the language
barrier number four visit the country
and build one-on-one relationships for
me I like the relationships always to be
through word of mouth because it's got
the highest level credibility so if I
say hey I'm looking for somebody who
does that that that I know this kind of
straddle it great then I sent an email
then we get on a call we jump on a Skype
if I can do Skype one that's what we'll
do
then we do a face-to-face
right because it's always face-to-face
personal relationship it's the highest
level but you may do a Skype and say I
don't really know if this is something
we want to do right now we said it's a
four year from now I think this is
something I got to go to Australia I've
got to go to this place to build our
relationship with them number five study
their marketing trends when I say
marketing trends Facebook is working for
your country it may not be working for
the other one YouTube may be big where
you're at but YouTube may be bad word
they're at they may do pay-per-click and
you may not do any paper clicks where
you're at you may be advertising on
Twitter they may never spend time on
Twitter you need to study their
marketing trans Derek Derek their groups
they're people the populace that's
buying the product you got to study
there's number six currency exchange
friendly billing and payments some
websites some key you know some portals
you use they're not friendly if currency
friendly you got to make sure you have
currency friendly so if the payments
being made you know to convert that
currency it's got to be easy to be done
I've done business for someone always
since I made a payment for six thousand
dollars wouldn't go through because the
currency exchange of anchored and
accepted you got asked with additional
questions from your bank on and your
merchant services account that you deal
with whoever it may be whatever portal
you use authorized.net whoever it is
that you use you gotta ask those
questions number seven one country at a
time you go seven at a time you're
spreading yourself too thin unless if
your name is GE and you have a seventeen
billion dollar budget different story if
you're not GE you don't have that kind
of a budget now you gotta make sure you
go one country at a time is to keep it
focused and then you're learning every
time you do a country you make that
other adjustment on the other countries
number eight move an ambassador anytime
I go to a new market that I don't know
that market but I'm moving somebody to
that market I move an ambassador because
that ambassador brings one thing when
Toyota came to the states the reason why
I Toyota did very well in the States is
because they moved their VP's from their
main plant that they had to America
because they had to transfer the culture
they notice it was a little bit more
sloppy a little bit more casual they
weren't as focused wait a minute this
took you three seconds more than it's
supposed to take thirty seconds is not a
big deal of course it is when we're
building all these cars you can't be
doing this mistake what is the big deal
about that this is how we do it in our
plant and this is how I need to be doing
an ambassador spreads that culture into
a market that doesn't yet do that number
nine is a governmental laws and
regulations a lot of times people don't
spend a lot of time thinking about you
gotta think about taxes like how China
works with 51% ownership or you have to
find the right people who are mom many
countries you go into you have to get a
relationship with somebody in the
government that favors you that you know
of somebody it's not the same as doing
business in every single country some
are a lot more complicated or difficult
and sometimes you go look at and say I
don't even know why I'm doing this I'm
only gonna make 13 percent on this not
including all the other fees and things
that they want to keep including the
taxes this makes no sense to me I have
no desire to go that even Oberer went
into China didn't work out they lost a
few billion dollars not everything makes
sense to pursue so study the
governmental laws and regulations taxes
spend that additional money with CPAs
attorneys for do that research for you
last but not least test test test test
as much as you can to find out what
worked in that country what didn't work
in that country we're gonna make that
adjustment here we're gonna move this
over here we're gonna put this over here
we're gonna change this service call
that we have we're gonna change the
script here we're gonna add that
overcome an objection this FAQ is gonna
have these three new objections that are
added and the way we overcome it is this
your consi testing the more you test is
then you eventually getting better and
by the way this helps you when you're
moving to the next country because
you've done so many tests you may learn
19 no mistakes that you would have never
learned but you don't make those
mistakes on this next country you're
going into source test test test test
test until you have a system on how to
take your business into a new country so
those are the ten points I'd give you
today on how to take your business
globally you got any questions thoughts
comments comment on the bottom and again
if you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel click on the subscribe button to
subscribe to value team and take you
everybody
oh by
[Music]